amber wrote in saying what would you
consider to be a useless college degree
alright that this is going to I'm sure
cause a variety of opinion some angry
and some happy there's sort of two ways
there's at least two ways that we can
answer this question one would be what
college degrees seem to not make sense
financially based on how much you're
likely to earn at the peak of your
career with that degree okay and that
brings up questions that we've been
asking like for example should it be
easy to get a two hundred thousand
dollar a student loan over the course of
four years in a field where you're
unlikely to ever make enough money to
pay that back that's a legitimate
question separate though is the question
of are there degrees that are useless to
society and I think that's a very
different question the financial
expected earnings of a degree so if you
look at what are the most useless
degrees type lists online usually you
see the same stuff communications and
liberal arts
psychology is often listed as an
undergraduate degree because most of the
people that are doing better in the
field of psychology have either a master
of social work or a sidee so that just
that the bachelor's degree in psychology
is not as useful theater I think the
oxygen see things like women studies
african-american studies for example so
a lot of the things that fall under
sociology which includes Women's Studies
and African American Studies etc are
often on these lists what I think those
lists miss are a couple different things
number one something like philosophy for
example which for a while was like the
caricature of the useless degree
increasingly you see everything from
tech startups to consulting firms to
government agencies thinking okay
technologically and logistically a lot
of what we do in our jobs can be taught
and it can be learned what types of
broader thinking skills are we
interested in people having which has
caused a resurgence in tech startups
hiring people with Philosophy degrees
history degrees etc so I think that
that's an interesting thing that's going
on in terms of the sort of value of a
lot of these jobs I reject the notion
that we should be
evaluating a degrees utility based on
expected earnings because many of these
degrees serve important social functions
I happen to think that teachers and
social workers are in many cases
significantly underpaid based on their
social value uh but that that doesn't
mean that pursuing those fields or a
degree in those fields is worthless I
think the problem is we're increasingly
going in the direction as we've talked
about before of needing a universal
basic income to balance out some of
these financial and consistencies across
jobs and I think the irony there is that
if you're going into a trade that may
not be a good investment for you in the
long term because if your job is
replaced by automation maybe you were
better off getting a liberal arts degree
and I think people always try to
stigmatize you know getting a liberal
arts or if you want any value they just
don't think it's going to be practical
or no one's going to be there's no
philosophy Factory down the street for
exactly but what it proves is writing
ability that's big and can be applied to
a lot of different jobs and also as you
said critical thinking skills and in the
economy that were going to be having
over the next generation those are two
of the most important things and I think
it can be applied to a lot of different
jobs I think the timing of the question
from amber about useless college degrees
is interesting because what we even mean
when we say that and what would be on
that list is probably in the middle of
some pretty radical change and sometimes
it's hard to notice the change when
you're in the middle of it as many
futurists say it's hard to notice
accelerating change because even
accelerating change can seem to happen
slowly I believe we are in the middle of
a change to that answer of what would be
useless college degrees I actually have
some a personal experience with this
because I majored in political science
and by the time I was a junior senior
year in college and there was really no
way to go back I was second-guessing
myself because I was thinking you know
maybe I can't get a tangible job out of
this because there may not be anything
that directly relates to what I'm
studying now luckily everything turned
out but I think you know whether it's
consulting or you know working for a
think-tank there's a lot of things that
maybe if they're not directly connected
they certainly are in some way and jobs
are going to find you and they're going
to want to hire people with those yeah
and like I said increasingly
the ability to say
in an idea economy is much more
important than what is increasingly a
homogenous set of tech skills that many
people are coming in already knowing
regardless of their field and companies
are finding out can be taught relatively
quickly it's very hard to teach someone
when they're 23 years old and in their
first job to communicate effectively in
a writing form to communicate ideas
effectively by speaking but you can
teach people everything from basic
coding to how to operate all sorts of
different electronics and machines
pretty quickly and it's also really
tough to ask an 18 year old what field
they want to go into the rest of their
lives because you know they're not
completely developed at that age and in
some countries that age where you kinda
have to make that choice is even younger
yes it is Argentina people don't do like
four years of bachelor's degree and then
go into medical school you go straight
into medical school and it's like a five
year program or something like that
writing at age 18 so if you do if you
know that you're not going to go into
the medical field or maybe engineering
or anything and you you see that yeah
there is a role out there for me but I
don't know exactly what it is a liberal
arts degree is actually probably your
best bet particularly in a world where
increasingly you might specialize at the
Masters level but of course with the
increased and affordability of college
that becomes harder to to assume unless
you really want to take on a lot of debt
we've got a great bonus show for you
today
you can sign up at david pakman.com
slash membership coupon code
I voted 17